shanky and also mentions that all the
colleagues work if they
every time Cheers
Oh
years
Curtis that those commercials we knew
these three seasons threatening those
videos by the way often taken to be
synonymous with me Jerry readings or to
the mystic germ that many think has
rendered obsolete the craft of in
sturdily rather we would have to reflect
no party and many more deeply on the
large continent that has grown out of
the broader country between the church
industry to use a note raise librarians
we all know the teacher has been stirred
size that it is not considered it is not
considered as social practice with
contentions nitrogen treaty borders and
definitions but between power-assisted
history sedation completely impacted the
question asked whether it's whorish
inversion where concepts under those
visual studies have informed the way
this
however his reflection shapes how their
readers questions that frame and carried
out the sermon in terms of context in
the more recent attempt to even hurt his
perspective on the church what happens
when his sermons hoop a torture but only
as an object but at the world and among
other things moving the word Authority
this question was raised something in
the March 2010 issue of the truth is
that not entitled to knowledge of
researchers we would have to expert
today keeping in mind the potential risk
of this to the researcher in the
singular which seems to refer to a
stable core of a universal human
activity to literature under the
historical production that in turn is
not as dramatic than the generic notion
of the historical experience that seems
to form the unpassable arrival also much
historical work the third and last layer
of
contents that is important for us today
in the upcoming masters in history
literature that the French and history
departments at cumbia we opened in Paris
in collaboration with economics and the
code it was it you know some some
startling in September 2011 we are
convinced that the questions raised
their earnings is history these future
masters are structural to the formation
of a new generation of students and
scholars in a context in which the
relevance of both history and history
this question once again all the
colleagues presented a under two more
are part of the team that put together
these masters and will make it work
in Paris
to cancel our trip the last minute
because of a personal emergency so thank
you for being here from reading these
conversations today and for the future
contributions and the delay I give it
over to our first one table that we
human everything by join us Tony thank
you
okay Thank You image all for including
me in this event I've been given very
strict instructions to only allow the
speakers to speak for 10 minutes so I
will adapt my prop
rest the microphone from the very
precise moments with ten minutes are
over
okay our first and then in that way we
will have a good amount of time for
discussion in this session I may run for
about two hours is there a break after
this because okay so we'll take a short
break after the presentations no no we
have to little thing okay so that we'll
hear from the four speakers and then
we'll have a good amount of time for
discussion our first speaker is cap
ropes professor of French and history at
Columbia is the author of self interest
before Adam Smith published by Cambridge
University Press in 2003 with the
paperback from 2007 he's also the author
of Modi'in who competed shows miliary
the price of things published by menthol
in 1994 and of the profit of pretending
I'm a new teacher
Escada published by behind
in 2009
published its current project on novelty
claims and early modern French
literature clients Thank You Joanna I
about an article I have just finished
and his method in intellectual history
yeah I do with
and impossible to support and encourage
who was very enthusiastic about his
studies about philosophy as a way of
life
and I do have
Camus but this
the article I just finished that
discusses something different which is
the number of theoretical and
methodological reflections
I know the name of the course of his
life which never systematize but which I
think are very interesting and
especially pertinent for our purpose
today now I do especially Stonehenge
philosophy with the technologists
historian is that he sought
philosophical foundation for his
activity
and you found that
philosophical foundation in his reading
a bit contrived and the dog was one of
the big green Stein's
earliest when Shriekers discovered in
1950 when no one in France had
and I thought says somewhere that he was
very much taken by one sentence there's
so much cryptic sentence in which time
that is and that sentence from the years
of Co investigations is the following
understanding the sentence is like
understanding the theme in music
understanding a musical so in the other
coleye I try to unpack this
I didn't sign and try to explain what it
meant for forehand oh and I'm going to
read just three pages from the article
in which I focus on this on this aspect
so I do credits finish time for showing
him that the primary function of
language is not to make objects or
designate sauce vintage-style
illustrates this point by describing the
way one speaks of the musical theme on
the one hand words seem unable to convey
what the particular musical theme is
about
I would like to say because I know what
it's all about but what is it all about
I should not be able to say
on the other hand using words to
describe a musical theme is it possible
for instance one when they make
comparisons with something else which
has the same rhythm or say things like
don't you see this is as if a conclusion
were being drawn or this is as it were
the parentheses the finish times use of
a musical example supports his political
stance against the Mentalist assessment
language that associates words and
sentences with in their images or
feelings and assumes that understanding
a sentence means having access in their
images or feelings if one assumes the
reality of those in their images of
feelings
it should be possible to describe them
in different ways and still designates
the same images or feelings yet witness
nine the opposite is true understanding
the musical theme means understanding
something that only this particular
theme says this is generally accepted in
the case of music because it is usually
assumed that
worth anything guilty with itself
vintage Stein's paradoxical Court is
that what is true of music is innocence
true of language in general now in the
lecture on aesthetics in which time
refers to the use of the phrase the man
is musical he notices that we got used
we do not use this phrase to designate
someone who says ha when the piece of
music is being played this would be
tantamount to calling the dog musical
because it has its tail when music is
being played
the man is musical when he is able to
play the language game that consists in
showing his appreciation of music at
first it seems very difficult if not
impossible to find words to describe
what the particular what is unique about
a particular piece but experience shows
that those who have good aesthetic
judgment managed to find words and
everything that works will do here
to agree with others who have according
to judgments that these words are being
well chosen the same analysis could be
made of the game that who consists in
describing the aroma of coffee or the
flavor of wine etc this neither prove
nor requires the existence of something
beyond the words themselves that who
made the agreement possible it simply
describes the language game that
consists in agree or disagree about the
characterization of the musical theme or
a sentence but in which time however the
musical and Allergan captures only one
aspect of what is going on in understand
your sentence and I quote we speak of
understanding the sentence in the
in which one can be replaced by another
which says the same but also in the
sense in which it can be cannot be
replaced by another any more than what
musical team can be replaced by another
in the one case the thought in the
sentence is something common two
different sentences in the other
something that is expressed only by
these words in these positions like
understanding the poem on the one hand
understanding the sentence means
understanding what is unique about this
sentence on the other hand it means
understanding something that could be
expressed in different way so the pitch
time these are not two separate and
unrelated meanings of understanding on
the contrary these kinds of views of
understanding make up its meaning make
up my concept of understanding this
analysis of understanding is
fundamentally important for
because it captures the contradiction
that is at the heart of historical
understanding in general and
intellectual history in particular on
the one hand the historian who's trying
to say what is unique about the
utterance we'll be very careful to avoid
anachronistic interpretations as
philosopher Kirsten was not particularly
interested in history but at all sees
his philosophy of language as supporting
the strongly historicist stands as the
peach banquet said what belongs to a
language game is a whole culture if you
want to describe useful taste between
people's mind says you have to describe
whether children in concerts whether we
will do or whether only if them
and here we have all the program of
cultural history a Japanese immigrants
in other words to describe the set of
aesthetic rules and I'm still working
means really to describe the culture of
the period so I know this is the
philosophical foundation of the
historians beauty - I put 8 for
objectivity and is possible truth it is
of paramount importance to avoid
anachronistic readings and to be
situated the words I quote within the
concrete conditions in which
this means looking at philosophical
rhetorical or poetic traditions and who
as well as material conditions including
the educational and social media and the
material constraints involved in
committing something to writing now add
those seemingly old-fashioned religions
to strict norms of objectivity is not
grounding in the belief that within all
texts in context will somehow give us as
access to things the s I don't wish
envision things as they actually happen
in different time terms this would be
just absurd as saying that understanding
the musical theme means understanding
the things it describes what makes the
strictly objective approach necessary is
the need to play the language game in
the right way and to do justice to what
is unique about a new operas or set our
audiences
on the other hand a fictitious between
central said the thought in the sentence
is something common to different
sentences what the text from the past
says can be sent in different words
without this torture distortion or
betrayal the same things can be said in
many different ways for a do this other
aspect of the meaning of understanding
is the philosophical foundation
deliberately present is a variation of
all steps as well as free willing
cross-cultural comparisons they stake in
reconstruction of the meaning of mention
author always yields the same
realization the meaning intended by the
entrance after his net worth current it
is actions and that's all there is to it
that is all there is to it
however ancient philosophies like
epicureanism or stoicism describe some
basic attitudes that are perfectly valid
today once they have been detached from
their historical context
similarly Abdul is comfortable throwing
parallels between he wrote and the
Chinese philosopher yaqoob who both
found wisdom in taking care of mundane
tasks and living their lives as
they're in the final analysis other
archers there are relatively few
possible attitudes with respect to our
existence and irrespective of historical
influence different civilizations have
been led to civil actions now I'll stop
here and bet and in between the
discussion I'll be happy to elaborate on
this aspect of either because he very
self-consciously and very clearly puts
together two positions that have
completely contradictory and his
position is that we have to affirm both
at the same time and that they are as
inputs a coincidence of opposites and
and and we plan to be both philosopher
and historian and in fact fully a
philosopher and historian and in order
to be
historian and vice versa
I'll be Matthew Jones who is associate
professor of history at Columbia
is the author of the good life
the state and a second project love
inclination and inertia the common good
thank you
they started the canonical text about
blocking historical and sociological now
young conductors are
great importance of the development of
intellectual property law for general
enemies me right for the most famous
passage quote an original may be said to
be of a vegetable nature it rises
spontaneously from the vital roots of
genius it grows it is not me
in contrast it says limitations are
often a sort of manufacturer brought up
by those mechanics art and labor out of
pre-existing materials
the point is very much to be a bulwark
against the dangers of the material is
imposed to literally an indication and
it was very much that program to try to
initiate a new vision of what it was to
create and to create new social
formations aren't just here is as I said
a bulwark against over a billion
historical nation young through come on
was a great importance to take on we
know that there was a contrast between
new
whereas it could make his discoveries
entirely intuitive Homer quote cannot
teach anyone else's method of creation
for quote he himself does not know it
now why I think this is important is
that in doing ministry when you're doing
history
very important to understand the nature
of the level of what it is we want to
historic sites and the limits that are
that are supposed either about ourselves
our mind of others and an analogy to
some older work in sociology of
knowledge so it might be useful to think
of it that kata me between a weak
sociology is very literary and strong
and the first one might be quite happy
living in institutions and productions
in genetics references one would
probably be fairly happy
with a Sinatra and
halation created lots of great
literature mechanically vs. genius and
the bottom of all the big loads of room
for reasserting the italian artist or
some sort of artist as a non truly
historical a strong sociology or history
of literary production I take it would
involve a definition of the artist that
was ever a localized and ever
institutionalized form
would be one in which the conditions of
production is one condition with taking
opera literature or literary products
with themselves fully historical and
it's one in which the very nature of the
production producer the objects and
subjects of literature would be defined
it is one of which meaning essence and
style all would be up for historical or
sociological excellent
yeah now we can all think of examples of
this that are profoundly deeply
reductant literature that's reductive
just as that is the historical work is
conducted to social conditions they take
it this is uninteresting to most of us
as is a sort of weak history of
literature about near institutions or
rather it seems that were interested
today this variety of approaches which
are interested in both the conditions of
possibility of production the conditions
of possibility of appropriation I think
that symmetry is central to the current
history of literature but why is the
conditions of possibility which is just
say what were interested in is the
historically specific conditions that we
make kinds of production possible and
kinda taking about the possible and by
possible I mean that contingencies that
are available as opposed to the
necessities that one has
now
and I think one of the most fertile
grounds for this is indeed to study as
it were the subject of the production
and appropriation of knowledge but how
to do this well I take it a program in
the history of literature and such as
SMA apparently impart an exploration of
the different ways one of my students
and I'm not necessarily like to call for
any particular one here door with a
coffee
want to go back to yogic injections
because it's a very peculiar document
talking that notice noted that for a
document that's all about the evils and
imitation it is a patchwork of quotation
stolen mothers was painful so together
we know strong and what's interesting
about it is that one of the
contradictions is just after how to
given this account of the original which
original is in distinguished to the
mechanical the manufacturer
because of that account of how it is the
artistic limitation
where we're in production and he does so
by bootstrapping in fact upon mechanical
he says a spirit of imitation as many
Filofax first surprised the liberal and
the wider arts that advantage which
mechanic enjoy in these men are ever
endeavouring to go beyond their process
without the mechanical in the former the
artistic to follow them and since copies
surpass not original extremes not rise
not higher than their spring rarely so
five hence while parts mechanic are
perpetual progress in injuries the
liberal or retrogradation and decay I
bring up this text is much to challenge
a trivial technology which Steve the
production of the modern author and of a
dream of a vision of the author over the
as Mirman Atticus as a mere part of that
and to know that in one of the context
of that story recessive the offices
happen that is the mechanical division
of the mechanical which is not used with
enormous interest in Young's foreclose
the possibility of explanation as it
were of true imitation of originals that
are artistic production okay primarily
because I don't think it's something you
would ever do but it locally is it not
in the sociological per se
of an effective analysis yeah he
contrasts good imitation with emulation
triangle yeah most importance in the
second half of the 18th century and one
thing very clear
he writes imitation is inferiority
confessed emulation is superiority
contested orthodontic imitation is
survived emulation generous back
feathers this fires that may give a name
this immortal this that is emulation
they happens to succeeding ages the rule
of taste and the standard of perfection
our men of genius start fire to each
other and kindled by conflict into
glories which no time shall extinguish
the same sentiment the same sentiment
resentment is easily found in stores
after sorts if you look up you'll find
precisely the production
the creation of conditions under which
one can have but through the innovative
it is emulation a voluntary courageous
sincere sentiment that makes the spirit
that makes it profit of great examples
and carries them well above often those
that is mine no as I said this kind of
effective exploration is not one that's
likely to appeal but it profoundly
interesting I think
now this is a second order account it's
a rather bizarre one in but it's one
that became embedded not into say merely
discussions about artistic production
but indeed became rather central to a
foundation or a whole series of
institution rounded precise
I'm creating an effective structure
capable of loading concrete political
economic change
so in 1778 society arts was founded in
Geneva 1 just like many many all across
France Germany and England the goal was
not unless they said that to excite by
the way accumulation the mind of artists
to observations and discoveries to call
to bring in every genre of Industry to
favor paper style useful establishments
and to sustain and support limitation
our our our industry this was foundation
ended up being absolutely crucial for
Geneva's dominance in lockni
No
this account at all and injustice at
Young's are Contras interesting because
it's a second-order story that is
clearly not a true
about understanding literary correction
yet it's the false it's a false yet true
it's a way of understanding and it's one
of the more productive of truth and
representative it had concrete effects
state support was costly education but
in non-obvious
I've given this story Norfolk to stress
the non Trippi ality of our efforts in
law
to challenge immateriality and they set
up some of the terms by which are some
of the things that we want to do
we constructed conditions of possibility
both production and appropriations in in
the 18th century
professor and chair of the department
published by Stanford in 1991
changing all this authorship and
creativity in the arts and sciences
during the long mid-century and she has
a research
yes when I was invited to participate
here in this round on literature and
history I decided I'm going to approach
this common attempt to think about
non-trivial ways of making this
connection between literature in history
by addressing the topic or the actually
literal history and I want to talk to me
about a new history of German literature
I brought with me look at it at some
point towards a topper and the new
history of German literature actually
took up the model of our colleagues in
French
neoui the new history of French
literature and actually quite
consciously imitated that model both of
these works have been have a lot in
common
that start out with the acknowledgement
of the destruction of almost all the
units that had traditionally guided the
scholarly writing of living histories
I'm going to give you a list of these
units the units of the author the period
the literary movement the jamba the
earth were the language and the nation
the only unit the new literary history
respected and in fact made strong was
the unit of the world literature as
represented commonly by the individual
literary text let me explain what I mean
by that by outlining the general design
of the new history of German literature
the book contains about 100 essays the
majority of which is devoted to ordinary
text the essays are written by different
authors not only literary scholars but
also historians philosophers art
historians and musicologists we've been
carefully selected but we've been given
the fairly precise instructions about
how to write the brief essay which was
not to be longer than 2,500 words and
which was to be written for educated lay
audience say the readers of The New
Yorker traditional literally histories
of moving for littering is mauryans
and for students of literature we aim to
in this project and add a quotation of
audience the subject of each essay which
our office has been assigned was in the
mouth
specific work of the litter which they
had to discuss in an essay that was to
bring out the particular reality and
relevance of that work for general
audience today in that sense the author
of the essay had to construct enough of
historical context that allowed to be
able to see the work as part of its time
but also as something special noteworthy
innovative and important enough to be
included in a complication
today Mahavir although all was an
English translation the authors of his
essays were encouraged to pay attention
to stylistic botanical and poetic
specifics to allow for quotes in the
essays that would make the literary text
living into the reader and ideally
inside the reader to seek out that text
on her on his own and read it in its
entirety of course you might want to
interject that the history of German
literature encompasses many more than
just 130
this is true however if you take up any
traditional literally history you will
find very very little attention to any
one particular literary text and it will
probably have to forget about the
citations
at best you will find summarizing
paragraph referring to some of the
greatest hits be that message that we
have a lot T orbiter prospect on by
contrast the moon it'll be history does
indeed pay a lot of attention to
individual livery texts albeit to a
limited number of approximately one
hundred now you might wonder how they
were chosen I won't elaborate to you and
all of the selection criteria and the
entire process of selection but merely
point out its underlying metonymic
principle for instance von Goethe's
passed over for the topics of the three
SS dedicated family twitter he selected
his early highly influential epistolary
novel doubt
but also the Roman elegies which show
not only an important aspect of
Germany's ongoing fascination with
classical antiquity and Mediterranean
culture but even more importantly a
radical and brother raised the approach
to erotic poetry and finally earned
espoused to not one the work of the very
old Buddha which escaped all available
generic categories of its time one that
has since been met as complex commentary
on industrialization and colonialism we
did not however select the influence
number of education minimizes failure
but instead instructed the author who
was asked to write on what McKenna's
Annihilus another novelist education an
important mid 19th century Swiss
contribution to be aware of the fact
that her essay was to be the main essay
of that impor
the German novel yet we did not only
select highly influential literary texts
as topics for these short essays but we
also select the text by non canonical
authors texts that would bring out the
one going changing status in nature of
the German language such as the
additional mass of the 17th century
humble merchant Widow
Littlefoot Harman or federate the
Great's essay do not even a human home
between invention condemning the
newfangled fashion of imitating
Shakespeare in German mobile we
solicited essays on certain
philosophical works on medium
technological interventions with a
wooden mark radio often as well as some
musical and visual works such as the
Magic Flute which was the first opera in
the German language so for my
description of the silic
the site for the new history of German
literature has highlighted one
implication for our question of how we
cope artists are sizing literature we
give a dominant status stood isolated
text which receives intensive attention
to detail which is explicate in such
that it becomes accessible and relevant
to the contemporary reader a procedure
which of course is not at all new but
well established in traditional
hermeneutics in this sense they still
new with regard to the approach to the
individual text what is however new
concerns the refusal to present literary
history with him over all honesty a
master block and who trace the rise
decline and fall of these units which
have been fragmented over the past 50
years or so in our discipline instead of
the comics even we have individual SS
these individual assets however has not
only been carefully selected according
to Mary
in view of the overall collection but
they also have each in the end cross
references to other related essays
finally and this is probably the most
traumatic rupture performed by this new
military history with any more
traditional literary histories instead
of a master plot which would provide an
object to the sequence of the individual
essays they are chronologically ordered
for each individual essay has a specific
date which precedes the title of the
essay in order to allow us the
sequencing of the individual essays our
authors were asked to choose a date
which would situate their has a visibly
a specific time they were also asked to
abstain whenever possible for merely
choosing the publication date and place
of the piece of literature
but to think of an event that was in
some form related to the SS subject but
not identical with it here would have
been an element of arbitrariness even
randomness with a much early in form of
writing history namely chronology they'd
be conclude by giving you a few examples
of these states that were chosen our
colleague after donto who wrote the
essay on Higgins lectures on aesthetics
preceded his entry about the end of art
with a date when Berlin saw the
construction of the Royal Art Museum
designed by a little shingle for my
essay on the popular late 16th century
Faust book I took as state the arrest of
a medical student in tubingen who had
been accused of having signed a pact
with the devil obviously as I hope to
make
with these two examples these histone
sizing moves not at all
aim and reducing the literary works to a
historical background not even to
explain the work in view of this urn
that event
nevertheless they might if successfully
chosen
mark the unique specificity of an entry
work which also consists exactly in its
very historicity and timeliness so I'd
like to conclude by in a way least way
what I do here to say visibly a project
of literary history that I guess it's me
or we can to make this the state of play
literary history deals with the fact
that we conceive them for their
littering he meant us danger God but at
the same time
is not fixed within a single temporal
order or pattern of historic community
professor of literature here at Columbia
she's also the general
the author of dirt for artists a focus
on trial from Adam over 2 million up
and she's author Bruce lesbianism
I think yeah
so I am taking a totally different
approach to this and I wrote out some
comments
no idea what to say so I wrote it down
during the time that I had thus far
spent in the Academy a student teacher
at scholar having beyond college in 1979
and graduate school in 1985 I witnessed
what it felt like a complete about-face
in terms of the relations between
literature and history and the
discipline of literary studies one of
the first things I learned upon entering
graduate school in the waning years of
high Clery was the biography in
particular and historical context in
general were entirely irrelevant to the
study of literature texts were texts
existing exclusively in relation to
themselves and to other texts any
suggestion of another approach was
quickly dismissed under the label of a
fallacy notably the pathetic referential
fallacy I was delighted
it's just concerted by this news I was
delighted because it seemed to invite me
to remain entirely ignorant of well the
same time disconcerted because the
information of question did appear to me
to be relevant nonetheless I happily
forged ahead with the exclusive pursuit
of intertextual referentiality pausing
only to consider whether any given enter
text I might discover where a Lincoln
story of Mary Kelly
after a wabbit began to dawn on me that
Michael riff attire of the main source
of my newfound knowledge that history
was irrelevant to the study of
literature was himself extremely
well-versed in the same areas he deemed
irrelevant and further that the very
arguments he used in dismissing
historical concerns were themselves
centrally informed by this erudition
I began to suspect that matters might be
a little less clear-cut than I had been
invited to believe still and I'm
embarrassed to admit this it was not
until I had already begun my
dissertation that it occurred to me that
it might not be such a bad idea after
all
to read George painters biography of
Cruz oh and even though I think this
project came to be more as an inspired
procrastination
might actually be abused I will spare
you the details suffice it to say that
painters biography despite the fact it
employs a somewhat circular methodology
to a great extent constructing a version
of Chris life extrapolated from his work
which it then uses to explain that but
I'm sure that there's a nothing for this
fallacy
anything the reading of it was a
stunning revelation that not only
greatly enriched my understanding of how
to end analysis of my subject but also
prevented me in a number of cases from
during truly Endicott conclusions or
rather more importantly from sharing
what with my dissertation committee some
of the idiotic conclusions I had already
drawn thus was I led to history a
subject I had energetically avoided as
an undergraduate following unfortunate
encounters with Samuel Eliot Morrison
and yield to death James's OBE I stopped
preaching the gospel of intertextuality
as the sole form of literary
referentiality which was a relief since
in truth my offended a bit of a strain
to believe that literature had nothing
to do with what I continued however unbe
erratically to think of as reality
appear to me to be a personal revelation
was in fact the tinny voice of the
zeitgeist the cultural studies under the
historicism whereby then firmly
ensconced in articles with titles like
are we being historical yet had been
appearing for death appeared in the 1988
actually have been appearing for some
time quickly followed by articles with
yet more Congress lead living titles
such as are we being theoretical
we still we were it's even being
historical unfortunately if
unsurprisingly literary scholars on the
rebound following that demolish their
embraced historicism that the same
degree of febrile excitement in which
they had formerly thrown themselves into
the pursuit of theory reified into an
exclusive doctrine to the point that
under the aegis of interdisciplinarity
literary studies have for some time been
willfully subsuming themselves into
something like a minor annex of
historical studies this is what the new
and and I'm basing that in part on my
experience on the selection board of the
Society of fellows in the humanities at
Columbia where very few dissertation a
great new proposals coming from
literature departments are actually
centrally literary but very with you but
instead most tend to use literature and
they were to make essentially historical
cultural history this is why the new ma
program in history in literature and
history is such a welcome innovation
with its emphasis on the interpolation
of the two fields my own experiences in
trying to negotiate the waters between
literature per se and history per se
means that by their first day have been
both illuminating and surprising to me
at least and so I propose to conclude by
saying a few words about how I came to
write my second book which was on
literary censorship trials and I have no
idea that this excursion into the realm
of history was going to be
I had for some time in a vague way been
intrigued by the number of now classic
works that have been suppressed or
occasioned the vicinity trials but uh
karate and they fell through month
obviously also Lisi Witte Chatterley's
Lover and the leader of my mother's the
references are not across to this
phenomenon tended to frame it as a
demonstration of the self-evident truth
that works of genius are always
transgressive and therefore viewed as
dangerous by those in power and they're
related and apparently equally
self-evident truth that they have not
been understood as works of genius in
their own time because of a combination
of visible prudishness or based
Philistine is Amanda failure to
recognize what we now know that is the
aforementioned idea that works of genius
are always transgressive and subversive
and the transgression and subversion
good thing I was perplexed by this
approach which I came to think of this
chronological chauvinism and I think it
had what's called present ISM in
historical studies I think the latest
attack
like all the problems will chauvinism
since it appeared to be predicated on an
essential superior and non-essential
unspoken have but also unquestioned
were unspoken and therefore also
unquestioned a sensual superiority of
the present to the past which seems to
me to be a bit short-sighted like
finding the sartorial fashions of ten
years ago
quaintly humorous without considering
the today's styles will inevitably look
like ten years hence this sort of
thinking is so exceedingly
unquestionably pervasive that I wondered
and otherwise intelligence speaker of
political scientist lament the fact that
well some people still believe in
progress narratives those book an
assertion predicated on the assumption
that we used to believe in progress
narratives but we have now moved beyond
that
I used to say that when they were passed
I decided to propose a conflict course
on literary censorship trials from those
mobile allowed through the US Supreme
Court decision in 1964 the theme Henry
Miller's Tropic of Cancer fit for
consumption by the American public
thirty years after its original
publication by the olympia press in
paris i then said about finding a
textbook that would place the works in
question and their trials in cultural
and legal history my intention was to
find something that i could both use
myself and preparing the course and
assigned to the students in fact
about this sort of history to my
surprise an alarm I could not find one
well there were a number of books that
discuss specific subtopics they all
dealt with national censorship histories
and they also all tended to be very
squarely and evidently coming from
either legal history perspective or a
literary studies perspective and really
not no one turned out that attempted to
look at the question internationally and
none of the books I found seemed really
to bridge the gap between literature
cultural history and legal history I
taught the course anyway a number of
times and this pipeline vishal feeling
that in order to be truly qualified i
should really go back and pursue at the
very least a JD as well as doctoral work
in history and
history I had eventually nonetheless
improved enough familiarity with the
subject to try to write the book and a
family hope to buy when embarking on the
enterprise and so I could buy I will
conclude with I think there are three
concluded three announcements
it was my hopeful little gestures of to
morning I will conclude with us out
there for with a small sample of the
sort of thing I discovered I tried to be
hysterical
what most surprised me when I started to
write the flow bath chapter which was I
had to write there's a there's a
historical overview prologue attendant
that chapters the first chapter in 1857
which is censorship trial was it the
first cut the editors of deliberative
body insisted on before they began
publishing but everybody in serial form
in 1856 was the most so the whole tree
tofu that poor Charles's mother sends
him weekly when his a medical student in
the wall well that was of course enraged
by this as by all the subsequent
depressions might seem to call and
companies amended in their efforts to
avoid censorious attention but the other
cuts the notorious Jack was seeing the
suppression of which was bringing up
precisely we have come English to avoid
for instance are understandable because
for the most part they concern sex and
never was edible to us because they the
concern sex with this particular detail
of censorship history
for the first time the utter strangeness
of the past the roast feet all seemed
entirely anodyne had therefore
incomprehensible as an object of the
program considered from a theoretical
angle it seemed to be a truly gratuitous
detail much more so for example than the
barometer that strangely chooses to
exemplify the gratuitous detail hallmark
of realism in the negative sanctum the
real tall says nothing we do not already
know about Charles as effective or
social media it does however whoever
effective or social media it does
however represent the first violation of
the rules of balls ation realism
according to which flew two figures
exclusively in literature as a marker of
either extravagance or penury before
flowba when characters sit down to
immediate French novels it is almost
always either lobsters washed down with
champagne or miserable soup made from
half a turnip scavenged from the gutters
seasoned within
this is actually not true of Dickens but
it does but other than Dickens it does
and to a great extent after as well
after some further investigation I began
to understand that this was in fact not
the only reason the Ender's that removed
the most of the vote
tree to a fool which was restituted when
a normal appeared in volume form after
the trial
1857 it was not only gratuitous but
ruinously corporeal without being sexy
and thus I finally realized belong to
the category of Monte Amiata Nesmith so
despised and derided by the likes of
thought they don't need a writer his
ferocious criticism of Laval and later
solo I had previously mistaken and as
pure hypocrisy coming from the author of
the scandalous short story collection
that included such memorable scenes as a
man who steals his lovers in other
regions with sealing-wax
in a jealous rage sex turned out not to
be always the ultimate transgressive
subject in the 19th century as we tend
to assume so I'm going to stop there
before you start wrestling the
microphone
and I just wanted to end by saying that
that other point very glad that
literature it is now pretty to refer to
things other than itself I also think
that would be really ashamed but if in
the in our zeal to be historical league
or to throw what present acoustical
literary
I get things started my first question
to
other speakers here something that I
have been hearing expressed a lot
go in the direction
as I've heard a number of colleagues
calling
I've heard it sideways but it seems to
you that one thing is insane is that
and the modern period perhaps it's even
more tempting
so it's also true though that everything
is literature time same so I'm just
depends how you look at it that's what's
so interesting about about the the early
Bach was about the early
Anthony early modern studies is that in
fact there isn't really a demarcation of
literature therefore you can look at it
as as not really existing in any kind of
meaningful way or on the contrary you
can boldly have everything else
but this in India
give the example of licorice thank
himself and of the airfare taxes and
anything the small books published
collection that is earlier article
he added a novel by a German scholar
from the 1970s about the importance of
the literary form ability in the finish
line that this scholar but Gottfried
Gabrielle who argues and this is
reachable so at was point of view that
the Kingston 20 words the Tractatus was
so attached to the literary form of the
book that he didn't want anything change
in the spelling document contribution
and he thought that the process that
Russell wrote to get ricotta's was the
dumbest thing because he gave a
paraphrase of the logical propositions
in the book and he did not understand
that the whole point of the book is the
literary experience of it that this is
the experience of bumping into against
the wall of language and this experience
is conveyed through the literary form of
the master and so if you translate the
book if you haven't read the book you
missed the entire point of the book so
therefore the the form is
and if you don't do the literary
analysis of the book you completely
missed the point of the book so so the
so he's strongly in is that in order to
understand philosophy you have to do
literary analysis
a reading of the text that doesn't
reduce its to powerful ideas but
right yes it's it's paying attention to
perform that is understanding that when
we detect the Tractatus which you read
these aphorisms and that there is an
experience and this is this is something
that cannot be said be shown and that's
the whole point of the practice and and
and doing the analysis of it literary
analysis that means showing that the
book is made up of aphorisms and that
this is the way it is meant to be and
that it is meant to convey this
experience of bumping against the whole
language that which can be achieved
which village- achieved through this
literary form of a person he could not
have achieved it was so
yes
well yes but it's it's the question is
the reference village mines is this man
to show this iniquity that is on the one
hand on the one hand a literary and for
him the literary and historical in that
sense cannot be distinguished on the one
hand you have to do justice to the
sentence what is neat about the sentence
it's like the scrubbing with the arm of
the governor and he goes very very far
in this in this in this direction and to
him it's the same thing as being
objective and and then there is the
other aspect which is paraphrase and and
paraphrase you can appropriate and in
the in the present its way whatever you
read from the past translation is
possible that translation then is the
question of how do you ran how do you do
justice to the work in a way that is
truly
and I just wanted to raise the question
of the leadership it was very
interesting when you mentioned that the
the the little history that you produced
is directed towards not well the layman
you know the read of the New York Times
as opposed obviously to you know what I
mean the word at the time of formalism
structuralism you know the the jargon
became so abstruse that finally the
readership was limited to the ivory
tower of academia so I'm just wondering
if we could raise this question of who
we are addressing in a when we do a
certain type of history cessation of
literature and and how the leadership of
you know this type of enterprise
compares with the leadership of
history of historiography
I guess we have different audiences in -
scholars depending on the venue we
choose right this I chose this example
of the new between history because I
guess I thought it put out in a way
most interesting by exactly not
addressing a specific scholarly audience
but by trying to address the big
audience namely I think on Chloe the
assumption that we still have that
literally text however we choose to
isolate and define this has a different
relationship to history then if we were
to consider that during his takes just a
historical document
I think the facts are that of course in
our professional lives
we usually address scholarly audiences
and I would also emphasize that actually
I think the best essays we gathered for
that rule in early history were written
by really excellent scholars but I think
it's an interesting exercise sort of to
see how I mean terms of the history of
living histories
what kind of readerships were imagined
exactly to make that connection
Matthew when I hear the words imitation
in addition I tend to hear those words
Atlantic
essentially
the issues in between
and then 4 p.m. in the discussion
you seem to
and make the assumption that literally
inclusively things are the same
that equals meaning is
like what we have is the idea that the
experience of meeting belongs to the
meaning test
I would say this is more important than
the forum itself it's the formalism was
not without the experience of reading
for many journals
message
interchange which we
when we had escaped
it has to do inexpensively so it's these
fascinating
- and the expensive it in which
innocence can and state of going but
after all
the experience of reading belongs to the
meaning which once get back
the second issue
is this
when you do
meeting is a closed meeting so wait
yes so the questions in other words
basically imitation and emulation
what if I can actually draw
what's the species you see the specimens
it was a rhetorical tradition the answer
is slightly asymmetrical actually in the
invitation but they both come out of
they both are central terms of the
rhetorical manual for their Aristotle in
translation for Antonia invitato is it's
both the fills in a sort of central term
of the articulations rather than put it
I think as importantly it builds into
the educational system for
and then that is that a maitake was not
only something one of the spouses but
the one experiences in the process so
that we know for example that Descartes
went for an education which part that
education was in maitake Oh which would
include taking a poem in one kind of
leader and imitating it and that this is
in an exercise that was to form one as a
certain time
a certain kind of person but also the
kind of person capable
of the full range of rhetorical skills
that was necessary not that that
they're sort of canonical history of
eating centered aesthetics that the
sufficiency of payment option has a term
for analyzing literary or artistic
production comes under great stuff
emulation that I'm interested again it
comes out of the economic is in
Aristotle's weather
there's much about psychology and it's
used early as really to discuss this
psychology of competition but it's a
technology professor
and so it becomes a way to understand
literary production but also you'll find
it very famously in humans jealousy
betrayed where there's a justification
of the legitimacy of competition in the
right way so there's aesthetic what was
this combined aesthetic emotive value
didn't become central for a reworking of
aesthetics but also a rethinking of
trade it's been in as well for a very
concrete product important subject it's
one in which one retains the good part
of in the talking without what is
increasingly seen as the negative
mechanical
so I have gone sort of much better think
about office
okay first question about the patient's
do I like to place the literary with
close
with aggravated says and just use the
term literally especially when it comes
the
in his comments when he had added this
article by gottfried Gabrielle this
flexion of essays he gave legal
precedent in which he says this is the
not call about the importance of the
literary form the finish line sorcery
and bye bye bye victory by literate or
he means the traditional categories of
literary analysis and in particular
Bashar and these very and certainly uses
these traditional categories of analysis
in his analysis of difficulty of
national context and he always
as from the from the stoic tradition and
said in order to have to understand this
text by Marcus Aurelius you have to
understand the shower it belongs to in
the vedic raja the textbook performs a
certain effect and for instance the in
the meditations you attended to patients
as concessional as showing them to
surprise like that but no you have to
understand that this belongs to the
shower
of Spiritual Exercises and these are
he's rehearsing techniques of stoic
meditation and and in to understand the
shark these techniques belong to then
you will not meet these words as
confessional
but I so so yeah if the plaintiff is of
context as well but that he's not I
think so much concerned with distinction
inclusive context and to attack with is
interested in the effect these and and
he is interested in he he does not here
is it so much but he's interested in in
rhetoric and his rhetoric and it's it's
absolutely essential to his open to this
approach and that syntax from the
sixties in which in the very precise way
says we we have lost this is pretty
parole and he says we have lost the
understanding of read what rhetoric
wasn't yet in activity we have to
retrieve this understanding and so he
was very aware of that and and then
there was a rediscovery of rhetoric but
that he he had thought about that
and so I thought it would have been
better worth never work yes is about
work Victor Michael didn't so it's
rhetorical reading so it's it's reading
how the reading of the text so but it's
the reading of the text insofar as it
has a certain effect on reader insofar
as it performs something
we have to explain
right now true
so it doesn't mean so obvious
Torian is he making kinda people call
each of those rules were
history of seems that we incur hopefully
by that but in philosophy
for this
well
yeah
ultimately I don't like his arguments
but but I I find it extremely
interesting because he first of all this
is some business someone so certainly
was not afraid of making this kind of
statement as infamy very much against
the zeitgeist about the necessity to
reach commit text in the in the
scientific way when you you do hear that
in France there's still quite a bit
especially that you don't know what the
one who dare to say that really text
scientifically or my biggest objective
but that this is really what you believe
my mind I'm striving to perform
objective scientific readings of pension
of entry tax and and they also have
thought of that as a spiritual exercise
that is the effort the objective isn't
itself the spiritual exercise and I also
find it interesting that he found a
philosophical justification for this in
which time this is not at all naive
positivism and he does not believe that
certain education is who is going to
reconstruct the past
or give us the things as as they were
it's it's about being as faithful as
possible to the sentence as it was
performed so and again if you define in
fights the justification for this
language but the the way the way he
looks at it from the times that you have
these these two opposite poles on the
one hand you have to be fully objective
on the other hand you have to allow
yourself and ultimately you have to
appropriate this thought for yourself in
a way that that doesn't care about
context at all in a completely present
attachment and how these two things are
connected is sort of a mystery but for
him it is a sort of crucial crucial
mystery and he talks about it in quite
like mystical terms he talks about
coincidence yeah opposite our own this
is an allusion to
Heraclitus to to the pre-socratics and
mystics who thought of reality be the
coincidence of opposites so he has this
this whole aspect which partly that's
that's isn't Harry enthusiastic and
quite quite extraordinary but different
it's sort of difficult to get into that
but but in that that's how you know
personally I'm perhaps that's
interesting me but I I would buy a sort
of classic hermetic argument gonna burst
out that then when you when you read the
text from the task the reading
historically is really experiencing the
transformation that the concept it's
really experiencing the transformations
that concepts from the past on the go as
we try to think in them so it's this
this dialogue between happen present
constant back and forth and
transformation so somewhere between
between complete stretch ness and
familiarity so Gavin argues that the
true curse of hermeneutics is somewhere
expansionist and complete familiarity
what I believe was was to hold those two
poles together complete the complete
strangeness of the past the past two
days is ready to strike and the complete
similarity of the present and he says
you have to be an ascetic or mystical
his work is is white is quite depressive
and I think the
the relation of it is quite impressive
that ultimately young
because you always mention the risk
reduction
so in a few minutes
what would a reduction
I mean I can find very specifically what
I meant was
to me that there's the
dimension that literature quoi
literature is not where people are
always it's very very often not what
people are studying I mean I used the
words that are airing this because this
was the obsession particularly tend to
find various
in what consists with her airiness now
one can certainly say
literature law literature got tossed out
there too in the pursuit of theoretical
paradigms and there
it's competition between
planting with berries but Sofia wait I'm
not parking back to about the time
various studies were concerned
literature that I've been very smart
players in the Society of fellows most
of the the vast majority of projects
that are proposed take from literature
departments take literary works in order
to prove an historical point they're not
only in literature it's
that may be a point about literature
about literary history has simply
stopped being Avenger focus that's
that's what
I'd say I began with that momentum
in order to set up not what we would
just completely tear down
and some things 133rd if if there is
something we want to retain there is
some literary and I think there's a
distraction it's very much there is it's
unclear what that would be
though this one oh that's what I was
gonna say whatever the case may be
whatever the case would be about this
room mystic quad that we tend to want to
retain I think there's a pragmatic
reason stacked this to thoroughgoing
we're not and that pragmatic is that one
tends to reduce the whole series that
same literature questions that have
traditionally been the problem
the very technique and those can tend to
be I would say a very pragmatically
reduce to something
into the social formation of the right
of this man thing rather than being
suggested I don't think there is an
opposition to the historical and the
what is to be doing that historical with
this kind of pragmatic attention and the
potential importance in the
then what would undertake a fully the
sort of historical analysis of literary
one would start probably with read
appreciating the way the rhetorical
tradition serves as a way for us to
understand the different the different
historical situated genre from there and
then that's that sort of rhetorical
approach would be to limit the sheer
diversity
my last part of this is 12 months has
done that I wanted to articulate this in
terms and conditions of possibility we
might be interested now I'm not saying
that we're toxic but they want my
pragmatically as a historian what
worried about in order to force to to
eliminate not only reductionism but the
TV ology yeah
catch the benefits
as you know my
and yet at historical questions about
being a fashion
- is it way to get into
it's not to get into the background it's
getting to the aspects of it
what you could imagine
simultaneously
and Brigade the artifice of the program
Aaron who was an artist that was
supposed to be producing some kind of
more transparent
that one one of you is our detailed
analysis
the age you know the pretense of a
behavior
and on the other hand it's nonetheless a
system of profound normal power and
there's no recent need to be
antithetical and so sort of simply focus
all this attention on safer gay and
baggage or the without say appreciating
yes it's a formal it's it's a it's a
it's a formal system where all sorts of
talk what I understand
is to sort of mistake the individual
production
and I think as a historian
your case in the 18th century the very
question saying the formal as
insufficient
I wish about chronology dirtiness
and it perhaps gets back to the issue of
audience with this type of
it's directed to when you start playing
chronology in so many ways that
publication date but choosing an event
with relationship with that work not
necessarily using
that has a very different effect on
leadership who know some of the nature
history
and you know the home
dispense with biography and historical
context because we knew it
with that background
you know the very interesting sort
of chronological experiment that an
anthology of this file
people knowing some other basic dates or
that it functions
well I mean it's a in a way it's a
chimera it was
it's more or less successful
it's written by many different authors
and there is actually quite a lot of
expectations attached me
since these are directed at general lay
audience the goofy I mean the video is
in a way invited to jump around read a
short essay and connect it with other
essays it's not encouraging and they
were reading yeah in the events that we
used for the chronological sequence in a
way bring out a certain randomness on
invitation whether we go to in a way
question
either way out to dinner to recompose
head I think what is good about
very evening for
exciting career city as the whole
project was
readers to invite them to seek out the
actual text and we really in its
entirety instead of providing a kind of
quick overall brand there are tips
and I did also say that in a way another
one is
soon as necessary background in a way
Islamic site it tends to be repeated is
what you know literally streets in to
copy from each other and which you will
find it any
you know yes I'm also lucky to comment
on that because it's different from the
French the new French history literature
in the French history of literature I
was I participated in at the time the
framework was done by the editors so
they chose all the dates yes so did we
the German is and you said each is a
minor could yanking me we allowed our
authors to choose the event every day
yes yes so ok met which was not the case
in the French this debate which means
that there was a framework it was not
the traditional literary history
framework but each article was related
to a date that had been chosen
so there was a sort of overall
philosophy of disturbing even though it
was a new feeling superior intended say
so but in your case what is a bit
troubling is that each article could be
based on a different conception and
philosophy history yes I mean in in that
sense yes
and if so it's much more much more handy
amazing said irrelevantly however and I
mean we discussed it with Denis and he
would actually emphasize the random
nature of the French theory history
whereas we tried in terms of how we how
we selected the text and how we selected
all of the others being in some bigger
not necessarily narratives but pay
attention particularly to the multiple
aspects of the history of the German
language were the question how much that
confirms German literature
me reality and the question of memory
and history a tradition we invited as we
have selected the authors and the topics
we invited some of them to pay
particular attention to these so there
was not an attempt to in a way impose
philosophy of history but to encourage
common fossae beyond the individual
interpretation or introduction or
whatever of course no someone should do
it a little early dinner yesterday we
did a lay in the sense that yeah I was
using in order to
Naha face the narrative he didn't
navigate
what about
Yuri
raisa every single question was about
say
well in a way you are answering your own
question by describing the place of the
more traditional livery history as right
now it's very much part of the curricula
of students of of literature and you
know we try to put it actually earlier
in the curriculum you know before the MA
in order to encourage students in a way
to get beyond it
but you know III really doubt that say
beyond students of literature there is
great interest in reading literally
histories I think it's very much
confined to a particular kind of
academic institution and
within that two kind of relatively now
interest are sort of a transition don't
people want to know what Romanticism
it's part of an interpretive traditions
in that sense it is human capital
another thing that I was taught in
graduate school is to have contempt for
those but in fact it turns out
eventually I realized that the author's
we were studying and their critics were
actually thinking in these categories
therefore they are germane and it does
help to know about them so I would say
that
today the speakers will have about 10
minutes each for their comments and then
we'll open up for discussion among the
speakers and without the audience so
it's a real pleasure for me today to
introduce our speakers my thanks for
coming
and our religious speakers one by one
the first speaker is on you professor in
the Department of French and professor
the shamily his author of numerous books
many of which at the intersection of
literature and history and literary
history the history literary
institutions his most recent book is
Luca v which was published with getting
now last year
good afternoon I would try to be very
simple and to try to give a response to
the question which has been put to us
how historical understandings I engaged
in by detail of a texts and traditions
today with this issue as number of us
have already done I will start with it
yet and of course where they are
producing the data bellick text a
document useful for historical research
I was of course threatening the
specificity of literature formalism here
the internal - the finalization even
though and where all these figures and
that the readiness of the same time
interrogation something the text
it indicates literature tended to be
isolated from historical and social
series
I'm a literary scholar a petition critic
but I'm also very early on did
historical research but it said that
books are at the intersection of
literature history I thought that I had
tried to maintain a distinction and
these were in fact two enterprises with
no pretense at mixing the Jones in a way
alternating books
and books of his early history or
cultural history or even history to go
the first being that was able to be
delayed Republican leaders published
almost 30 years ago which was a history
of the discipline of living history
other books were one of us on key
figures and web published in series of
history such as a book which I just
mentioned fate one as I said I never
tried
I quite never to mix their songs
and neither is a glitch which I often
talk between two approaches which is
issues annotations synergy
problem post - whoopsie recently one
should not forget that fidelity remains
the foundation of our discipline
we did of literally tests let me however
these these minutes just invert the
couple of simple instances that I have
been counted in my Scully experience of
more specific contributions of
literature literature and of course the
general scholarship to historical
knowledge or understanding and I will
import examples
first one is a very obvious very simple
very positivistic literature can not
only help to establish historical facts
but in certain instances it is
instrument it can be the only way to
establish historical facts we could find
examples oppose this and now sponsoring
a dissertation by an exceptional
Japanese student usually what gave me
this dissertation is on the train
through severe English on some terries
boosts first unfinished
attempt in the course of his research
which is
this doctoral students checked the
number of informations as he found in
post or tried to understand the
complexity of allusions that are present
in the lives of living death
but also a style degasification
and he was led to revise basic facts
about facts that had escaped official
histories and imitated by everybody
afterwards he had to go back to the
original sources which is the class and
guys
complicates the official history of some
defense for that Ernests and even dates
of the historians will have to realize
elements of the quality of the places
affair based on this dissipation in fact
they're already turnings and this is
what I want he was specific two years
ago at the confluence presented some of
his discoveries and they ended up with a
distribution in a chance
so simply to remind you that the close
reading
after the best known historical events
we all knew everything that had to be
known about it
in that vein I could cite minute example
of let's call it all history lost to
other sources but surviving in nature
like to question reminiscences that
waiting to me
least literature is in mine the truth of
memories
second line
he does it he started understanding
finish I would take it from me totally
different
one which was alluded to earlier in the
first session
I think that one should mention the
exploited nearly exceptional mode of the
deception
the tradition the transmission of Hitler
Germany in dining history tell referred
to the immunity circle
dialectic straight nations from
indemnity the reception of literature is
one of the most effective and plays into
the history of mentality
number of years ago it was in 90
I would work on the reception of
that the occasion was the fourth 400 yes
and personally contains death in 1592
and I analyze the reception of
essays in a number of occasions
significant moments coming ovations 1892
33 the University of Pittsburgh 1890 the
first edition of the essays and 19
they made a distinction visible that
were considered logical reading and I
think of invading which were mentioned
in a way earlier yet this is a vertical
reading which is in search of the
original meaning even though they never
assumes that this original meeting will
be finished and have ago equal reading
which is a way of
index of being interested in meaning
which it has for us which is already in
deep with anybody
the text is always in between philology
and having the way and the study of the
reception in particular of such a
diverse surveys as mentioning is an
extraordinary window into spaces
interpretation cultural context
literally traditions are highly
informative of the evolution of
mentality the third example the third
set of contributions of literature to
historical inquiry
these precisely with representations or
cultural history again let me mention a
couple of examples
originated in the critical editions of
post to which they participated for
instance
I would remember he says on various
aspects of anti-semitism at the time of
course that had not been with such
consensus the presence of Jews in the
new beach resorts of Normandy where a
synagogue was built at the time of
forces since then of course is sort of
has taken up by social history and there
are articles on the Jews it back there
Otto Jerusalem other resource though he
was an extension of the book activist
the planning so where the Jewish
mythology was moving
I do not invite them literature is the
only source for such
of history but it is one that unders
issues manifest that makes one sensitive
to them this is why this is the reason
why historians of sensibility has turned
to literature extensively and most
effectively me two books on prostitution
smell noises or recently voices the book
for which she don't remember eating sex
she could have referred to post as
historians of sensibility
I think know the dimensions of stew they
had born of literature's particular
sensibilities of privileged entry into
new fields and objects of research that
now because of their nature be
wrongfully to the
of the Astoria but let me mention before
flame briefly again this is not
literature what literature but still so
to speak literature as an entry into a
new history
literature class leadership is language
production collective memory of language
embedded in the distance in my mind the
most relevant contribution of literature
history has to do with its peculiar year
to language with its sensibility to this
course I remember writing for instance I
think once to nautical on one adjective
enforces still again
trying to toss that it opened a whole
world of cultural representations ideas
events politics of the late 19th century
this leads us back to phonology
literature contributes to historical
knowledge or understanding essentially
who is sensibility to language and
discourse one word in the poem no I said
one word contain the word toss for
instance we need to a whole new
understanding of the network literature
is collective memory
because it'd be of all history which I
will also go in indexed rally and in
Catholic strategy for me is not only
that also culture most my work if it has
continued to a better historical
understanding organization has that with
literature has as cultural index charity
and I think this is where the
contribution as literature is the most
thank you very much well as we did in
the first session we'll hold questions
in our second speaker is community is
the author
he's currently director of the show
journal and our discussion today
his turn
usually an undeveloped relationship to
eternity treasure most of them are
voracious readers of literally text
especially knows and immediately
acknowledged the incidence of these
readings and their world is to come
works from Jaws DB the claim that you
will not pass went from us but to Jack
the girl who confess that a large part
of his historical imagination work was
fashioned by what was called numbers
there is a long list of senior debt of
gratitude and whether some great studies
were also read writers from Voltaire
loosely and even to put them however
when it comes time to define the
theoretical connection between history
and literature history often adopt a
very defensive attitude tracking
frontiers that resemble the regular
channel there are some older women
leaders for this attitude the tablet
fact that history became an academy
in the 9th century but a certainty it's
different from their lead and from the
rhetorical tradition Animas tracing
explains further with the addition and
light later with the social the social
sciences but more recent reasons must be
mentioned first the naughty list and
linguistic offensive against the
scientific claims of social history
beginning in the 1970s one things of
course of its operating work or even
political was received by most
historians and the threat and let them
to adopt a more positive attitude this
was especially true in front in the
French context which was marked by
the success of historical fiction and in
particular from the the attraction of
controversy literature vexed aquifers of
distant history such as mobile children
has sometimes denounced by historians as
an illegitimate and dangerous conference
that the leader in reference to the
controversy led by to be I don't need
anyone's respect to biography of nazy
torture these conferences were revived
last year we are debating friends around
Lancaster in reaction to this defensive
attitude some researchers have tried to
reverse the poor mother desperately
instead of asking if history is
beneficial
they try to understand the cognitive
powers of literature the historical
sociological
and even scientific knowledge that
literature produces carries in specific
historical context this is a broad topic
which we try to present in a recent
patent issue sub-module so I will focus
instead a more specific question namely
our account of human experience of time
my quality is that in literature and
against this historical knowledge it is
not so much because of some the pre-war
ability to make the path to life or the
reader of fiction but rather because I
do because in
so let me focus briefly and to Brittany
on
the third one is quite paradigmatic
salvific very educational to hotel is
very professional which has been the
most studied by historians and social
science who you as new chosen as
both of these both strongly pussies
neurotic choices have committed meeting
implications
my heart good mark is not be known as
historical historical reality and yet as
each animal has tried to catch novels
can be read as engaged the soul of time
this is not this is not you say that had
to juice a vertical reflection on this
question and the fact is this
consideration of history or rather
deceptive the Donati choices in his
novels especially
men sensitive do too much college plans
of time informed and waiting even memory
and war what is especially is pairing
from historical perspective
the English word is
historical consciousness some sinner
came to the knowledge of time but Raisa
rather the writing of bad things the way
that Naruto's organized in molarity
their memories and experiences of
talented elders as where to destroy
sighs this process with attitude of
different she's worth remembering that
God wrote is novels during the period
where when French mr. Brantley was not
interested in the subjects of historical
times
and polarized the discussion in the
superficial opposition with the
cherished foundation and didn't attend
from this point of view it is possible
to say that literature with gratitude
children suppose writers at this moment
depository of vast knowledge the fact
that historical time is constituted of
different varieties and
by the great German title
general Chapman our time was crucial
aristocrat and the chief of the land
forces in 1933 this book has a very
uncertain status it
the most obvious feature of imaginary
dialogue between the main characters -
self and soul is related these dieters
belong to northern literary form the
dire and I cannot think of one modern
history who use it in a canister
and yet everybody knows this is too
deeply to death with those who had
disappeared for a long time
this fear no one wanted to dress like to
death and history with you two people of
the past the shadows have to learn to
ride this idea that history modern
culture is the collective way
on the other hand some historians have a
much older way of telling people of the
past as mere objects of science the
Emperor and then conclude by quoting the
policies that the mandersohn
as America's fastest oratory
experimentations is to warn us against
this force afternoon and against the
temptation to judge the men of the past
history
sorry which is most germane to the
things we're discussing today
to travel for knowledge he's probably
two days
characterized collectively as literally
that takes in what other forms of
discourse do not capture
it is a matter also qualification of
this mission and boundary drawing and it
is a matter of subversion of boundaries
this is not only because each other
portion through trades historically in
continuum but also because each other or
West transcends category categorization
this to hysteresis as literature also
means to explore over time the boundary
between the boundaries between digital
and other forms of knowledge that
permits complete with it and exclude or
our experiments the history of a number
of knowledge discipline have be marked
by normal some form of the translational
discourse the discipline of history
since it was first constituted as a
discipline in the nineteenth century
another example is product which has
repeatedly experiences experienced
moment
these musician or of linearization the
18th century of course but also for
example the existence moment yet another
is medicine
which have been a producer of knowledge
about literature its effects on the
vegetable in refugees to put their mind
as well as a producer of text that is
good for the children Thanks position
the community
and which for recently in the field of
narrative medicine
interest in literature as a way to
continue different knowledge and
passions and latitude 40 or
understanding stories of illness so that
knowledge of the truth text African
tools for their positions so we turn to
Agora for me to have them from work I
want to stress that it's the rise of the
social sciences of the 19th century that
work the question of the boundaries
between various form of knowledge to a
head as this well done the social
sciences
not at first constitute well-defined
kill characterized by certain specific
institutional and methods the rather
embody a huge range of investigations
and confessing
administration and the ranch of more or
less radical social reforms in the first
decades of the 19th century if you're
constructing the science of social life
that would seek to identify facts
explain the polarities and we used the
nuances of society to the limited number
of times was inspired as much by veturi
ambitions by the 1830s and 40s as local
regional and national studies of such
activities will be pursued from Europe
that could claim you're flying sites of
nature the studies of special man and I
wanna know what is the thing from shaft
a title of doctor ask yourself what we
see here is a distinctive historical
moment the moment of contradiction of
the soul in a wider variety of scholarly
and for literary texts some which the
little ones circulated widely white
while others enjoy more limited
leadership this moment has been
described target where my story what
often being intrigued by the place of
literature in the prehistory of social
sciences recently
agent forties were three subunits but
throughout during which the dividing
line - Richard Durand
human ambiguous nature we are told in
this article was a way of exploring
questions that were subsequently claimed
by the disciplines literature was
a place for interpreted understatement
especially developed and in defending
that would never met Oprah purely
descriptive not purely theoretical
indeed the great social circles of the
40s conduct at the time when to ravage
the ravages of a district development
both cities and suburbs were first
coming to light described and analyzed
poverty using the same methods of
dualistic literature of the very
realistic literature which is
distinctive methods of way of saying and
creating portrait of society something
to be explored a new path object to be
deciphered as body to detect shared with
wait
distinctives ways of controversial world
as in Texas this specific point is time
but also moment when digital has been
stabbed inside as a corporate austex
and as the social
eventually disconnector unraveled
however insofar as the magnetization of
support Social Sciences ledger signify
the rejection of literature they for
example exclusion of Israel
yet we also know that the church were
who are writing and fiction was
continually reintroduced to Social
Sciences whenever it was necessary to
produce I think with descriptions or to
nutrient-dense
here the world of including the observer
and the picture or to demonstrate
offensive acidity Hollywood image erotic
stuff with workable style of scholarly
writing for the purpose of the history
of the social sciences instead of asking
about the literary nature of geological
or interpolation untrue political
knowledge and writing will do better to
straight is appeal to literature
precisely
to the situation of the disciplinary few
themselves and in relation to the career
of the scholars part of the technical
demands work seems to me direction so
the way
well this set of very dense articles
clearly reveals is that a repressive
traces point history what people call
literature provided a way of
understanding describing thinking about
and repairing the world but there is
also something else for example bas
Rutten interaction makes it possible to
consider on the historicity of human
experience
time and that this reflectiveness which
was which was interested literature of
the period should be turned back into
itself the issue of another what tends
to point quite strongly to studies to
stabilize somewhat certain someone new
division between nature and history this
division is particularly explicit and
suggested and that was unity in the part
of the issue devoted to the reviews of
interpretation by sociologist and
historian the social sciences and
historical science in particular probing
on their ability to situate and destroy
style literature good and forth
interpreted
in such a way to express his knowledge
of time history and social experience
the probably the fourth in a sense to go
beyond what we have done and learn to do
so far to produce context
extra life that at the same times to
produce knowledge that subtracts text in
the past to understand where fast they
originated the original in and how they
move out of it and to grasp the way in
which they convey the customers when
they make a steel what might what might
need to be done for this renovation that
is continue to insist on the mister
Richard quite what taking into account
the way which literature as an
experience of reading challenges
historical knowledge in the presence
thank you
our fourth speaker is Seminole boy who
is professor in the Department of
History at Columbia and co-directed in
social for intellectual and cultural
history he's the author of several books
including a human last utopia human
rights all right thanks very much I've
decided to approach our topic from a
relatively narrow perspective just about
my own self discipline which is modern
European intellectual history and as
their own part because this sub
discipline has no exact equivalent even
in England let alone
Europe nonetheless it has its own cannon
and way of approaching these matters
across the decades and I thought would
be interesting to review some of those
maybe instead of unfamiliar names
hopefully raised issues
professor Cole thought you had four
marks I'll have four stages and I'm
gonna start out with the first which is
really the forging of the stock
discipline in the United States which
occurred at Johns Hopkins University the
offices that history of ideas in the
early part of the 20th century now
what's remarkable about this founding
which of course led later to the
flagship journal the Journal of history
idea is that it was a fully
interdisciplinary project from the start
and incorporated literature as part of
the history of ideas its leader was mark
there Lovejoy a philosopher but he had
lots of interlocutors in his club with
literary scholars and even some major
critics from
a most romantic ologists like yes this
earth if you look back there's a certain
antiquarianism that rightfully attaches
to Lovejoy's work including his greatest
book the great chain of being it's a
story that book about the history of
platonic or more accurately Neoplatonic
emanation ism this reversal across two
millennia into its opposite but even
though lockjaw has been ritually slayed
by every succeeding generation of
intellectual historian sense actually I
think his project retains considerable
interest and not least from the point of
view work is there today he did even in
that book try to fully incorporate the
literary evidence treating it as
something essentially on par with
philosophy that may be worth as saying
why essentially I think it's because you
saw no reason not to see literature is
this potential site of appearance of
conceptual 'ti or even as the space of
conceptual 'ti
from philosophy so even though training
some philosopher he hoped to not topple
philosophy but a sea conceptuality or
what he called the history of human
ideas as appearing essentially anywhere
potentially including in my culture and
certainly across the disciplines
now of course he paid a price for this
generosity because he opened himself to
the risk of seeing literature is nothing
else but a sight appearance for these
famous unit ideas so for example
immigration of being he cited some lines
in poetry from Alexander Pope the sort
of the epitome of the great chain of
being
literary nough Swizz not something that
he took especially seriously
so his interdisciplinarity came to rice
I don't know whether you have a program
given this generosity after the war and
I moved to my second stage it's in this
era that intellectual history was
founded or rebounded to my knowledge
intellectual history as a phrase in
English hadn't existed up until the
post-war period and in some ways it is
it displaces the historic ideas which is
now kind of fossilized in the title of
that journal I mentioned but very few
people call themselves historians of
ideas there's an even more forgotten
figure who epitomizes intellectual
history in this era taught at Harvard
named Stuart Hughes who once again I
think impresses us in retrospect
for his interdisciplinary commitments
which were subsequently lost which
included literature his great book was
called consciousness in a society from
the late fifties now like lots of people
including the Englishman Quentin Skinner
I won't mention since I'm restricting my
view to the United States huge rival
against the definition of the object of
study of intellectual history as contest
and so he tries to provide a kind of
richer approach
but it was one that preserves space
through literature through thinking
about intellectual history and study of
the zeitgeist and so what he did and his
famous book was try to reconstruct a
so-called revolt against positivism that
exploded in 1890s and lasted through the
interwar period and he actually has
rather extended breathing's of thomas
manasa boost in this book again as kind
of tokens of the supposed crisis of
positivism and the revolt against it
once again there's the generous
inclusion of literature in the field but
mainly as a kind of tokenism generous in
that it brings the literature let's say
up to the level of philosophy or brings
philosophy up to the level
literature but only by putting them on a
kind of homogenizing bar another example
of this you might find in the other
classic that appear they'll publish much
later a contemporary of Hughes's named
Carl Erskine who wrote a famous book
called fantasy at Vienna which just like
Hughes tried to very self-consciously to
across genres and disciplines not only
by including literature by the way also
including
what's happened since then in the third
stage I think I would identify a kind of
era destabilization from which we're
still in a sense trying to recover of
course from inside the literary cabinet
there are considerable continuities
between earlier formal estimate
journalist methods throughout the 20th
century than the rise of deconstruction
and other theoretically influence modes
but for historians I think the rise of
so-called French theory was what stuff
is a kind of moment at the end of you
know kind of humanists criticism which
allow for the incorporation of
literature before which now seem much
more difficult many of the most
prominent European intellectual
historians again in the United States
addressing modern topics simply stopped
incorporating literature which was
really I think a great tradition as I
suggested the premier intellectual
historian named Martin J really has
never addressed any work of literature
in his life although he championed that
method he called the textual approach to
intellectual history literature didn't
think here amongst the text another
representative of that generation has
been mentioned by Antoine Dominic
macabre if you like
ended up being the exception who proved
the rule he adopted the formalist
methods and internalist attitudes of
French Erie and the literary trends of
the day it remains a rather impressive
project I think to return to the Capra's
writings he in a sense wanted to treat
philosophy and other theoretical texts
much the same way that a literary critic
order idiom might treat literary text
and his readings are often extremely
impressive
I want mentioned that he wants published
an article on a sentimental education in
fact that appeared in Nam I think it was
about their isolated episode of the
journal and I remember when I was a good
classroom chocolate came to Berkeley
I think it's fair to say that if you
look at the very large number of modern
intellectual historians working in the
ear essence this destabilization this
interdisciplinarity has been preserved
but only in teaching with a few isolated
and dominant with a breath while
influential has been so mainly as a
critic of other historians not for
providing any sort of model or
contemporary collection of history at
least not in our day it seems to be in
the era of founding this MA program we
therefore at least when the perspective
of my home doesn't want to face it kind
of very specific conjuncture on the one
hand it has been discussed by professor
layton center there seems across the
departmental boundary to be a kind of
waning of the formalism and in turn
unless that lets the destabilization in
the first place and it seems often in
fact isset literature professors would
like nothing more than to be
intellectual historians the new
historicism was part of that trend but
it's more often that one finds it in
recent decades since the creation of the
New Historicism that specifically
intellectual history to the high
cholestoral status of literature is
what's often being practiced by
literature professors after the New
Historicism in private the real
historians often wonder how much
historicism that really is in this term
to history but it's nonetheless an
impressive end for potentially fruitful
development but it competes with another
development within history departments
and it's quite a remarkable one for most
the year I've been talking about
intellectual history was not an approved
time there were very few people in
history departments who pursued it
and in the era of the destabilization it
was marginalized yet further by the rise
of very sophisticated forms of social
history and cultural history but those
themselves have waned and not least at
Columbia University where the department
which was once a bastion of Marxist
inspired social history has hired a
goodly number of intellectual historians
Matthew me several others and more
interestingly many people who were
trained as political and social
historians have worked in intellectual
history in various ways this I think it
leaves us in a particular laundry which
is that a success through dissolution
through the discipline and even across
disciplinary orders in places where
once ready there's another development
which is we've really passed the age of
let's say theoretical controversy did
intellectual history the age of what
Capra and others was an age in which the
greatest premium was placed on having a
specific methodological approach and the
age of this dissolution of the sub
discipline into history and Beyond is
also the rise kind of eclecticism in
which it doesn't matter much what method
one adopts in intellectual history or
one switches amongst methods depending
on one's subject so if that's the case
it seems to me we should reckon with the
attempt to bridge the gap between
history and literature and age that
probably best described is one of the
classism
I'm just a reflection especially about
the period you mentioned which is a
sorry to yourself is early but
romanticism and this was a time in the
19th century when like you said
literature and most specifically the
novel and history were both trying to
define or redefine themselves very much
against each other against meaning not
just in a position to between in contact
with each other in very close contact
with each other it was a time when a lot
of the novelist also historians young
team etc and and when historians took
the novel very seriously somebody
mentioned I think Jude that Judy was
very much influenced by water scarred
but Sharon you know historian without
water Scott so and and something that
that came about at this time was the
very stone wall which is a very
interesting sharp is still very popular
today although I don't think it is
the same ambitions as he had at the time
obviously very very much dependent on
historiography but at the same time
claim you to produce historical
knowledge so you know this is just
something came to mind the importance of
the historical normal and you mentioned
you know the importance of of historical
novel for knowledge
you claim to have been influenced by the
part of Scott since his country but the
got the power to make it that is very
often under strive recognition of the
relationship
the question but that in the issue we
asked these studies or social scientists
scientists to write a very sort of
review of a contemporary novel published
in two or three last year's and to solve
just sort of experiments experimentation
and it's very interesting to see how
it's interesting for us there what we do
historical novels well to make and
compare it with
because what you have schematic what I'm
going to say but what you have first
became
century the situation where you have
well writers producing historical novels
and challenging sisters the writing
in the moment for the discipline of
history building health himself and the
if we if we observe what what's going on
in the show is an ad from this point
what do you see you see
productions
these are writings that try to make
something of the evolution on these
terms of writing itself historical
writing sources
you have a different relationship
between the different production itself
20th century and the historical
knowledge that you have you are writers
who look at historical knowledge as
something that they have to deal with as
visual writers and at the same time you
have historians
explain
reduce texts on their stroke on their
experience of literature has a story
this is
partition of knowledge between history
and literature that history is tagged to
take into account to explain into
explicit exactly what they do when they
reach the Torah text important this is
something that we have to work to
observe and maybe also to situate our
new situation
I hadn't
the
the status of
your logical method in new developments
an entry learned from this station
advisor for Jesuit priest who was first
and foremost pathologist and we didn't
have many ideas but we have only one
exit
really but the bedrock is method is that
one should look with intellectual
historians are in the business of
looking for the quality we want to look
for neutral orange not a triangle one
that is easy to find molarity
and in which he puts phenology at the
center
the social sciences and which he says
the
and technologist is really this eclectic
scholar the philologist
in order to understand that local
collections from the past has to be a
little bit philosopher a little bit of a
taste a little bit of the origin and all
these sort of eclectic bits of knowledge
converge
I think I agree with the spirit of those
of your remarks been speaking as the
modernist these Phil illogical methods
are often ones that are not off but have
to be learned in a sense through
following examples or reinventing the
logical methods without coming
from teachers I would expect in math you
might speak about this historians of
ideas who work at earlier periods would
have better training
I think you're right I think that
traditional questions that the
intellectual asourian's ask about
sources of influence are our best
dressed person or most
more or less illogical habits
I think electus ism has arisen because
philology has ceased to be interesting
at least as a kind of self submission
method I think you're right that it
ought to be at the center but because
it's so often seen as a boring
preliminary it's not place given near
enough in workers its downfall of course
is that you know it one reads went and
Skinner or practically anyone eclectus
it's our ecology doesn't give us much to
go on
in thinking about interpreting meaning
or it does so in very vulgar ways that
that allows tracing of relatively simple
influence racketing more more complex
sorts of connections at least in a
stereotyped apology and and more
importantly philology tends to bracket
problems of causation
it describes influences without
explaining why certain ideas are taken
up and here is its social sociological
traditions of studying the Marxist ones
which have always been working to the
point of displacing philology from its
kind of central area
yeah
you made me think of in the sense that
you know in that piece
brainerd could see protons in Israel
complexion
so wondering where you would situate
sort of that opposition between those
two approaches to remote literature and
second question which I guess is related
to the persons
about why don't model
so I'll defer really to Alphonse who's
much more of an expert in the period
even though we both attend rather survey
reviews about Jonathan Israel's work
well this day very briefly that's I'm
not sure if if philology provides an
adequate way of distinguishing between
Israel and Palestine in some ways it's a
little seems to be hampered by his bill
illogical focus on Spinoza and in fact
when when he read my review of his work
and my championship of dance book as a
kind of alternative his complaint was
that Dan in a sense looks at naturalism
and much too vague away across the 18th
century rather than focusing on the
statistic approach to nature and
particular so that I don't know if
everyone's read Dan's book or no one but
he he looks it at various sorts of
discourses of nature in 18th century
thought before leaving
to the French Revolution and it's called
adventure and so that might be right but
I still wouldn't prefer Dan's book and
so I just wondered that's really their
respective attitudes towards philology
that would help us distinguish between
them Dominic's work
I think became he made himself into a
gadfly to discipline rather than never
trying to operationalize his method so
famously he wrote extremely I think
brilliant criticisms people like Robert
dark
proposed two terms in the history of
those almost without reading them
anymore and this I think correctly
raised Dominic's
apples
his own alternative was really a kind of
internalized sort of reading and that's
epitomize I think by the article in the
amount original topographer which is
maybe properly earned chocolate does
content it's hard to see exactly what is
historical about anyone in his own
career he never really wrote a work of
history hero
without the on trial which would be the
only possible campaign for a kind of
actual performance of what you preach
and it's very very good book very
interesting book but it's not one that
was widely read so he he was really
taken as more kind of external critic of
other people's performances rather than
being bold enough to offer his own
I received a relationship with the
Enlightenment very the Enlightenment
relationship the legacy of uniting below
DPM people because the natural right
because because
and that from the striker point of view
it's a very important difference the
relationship
and the second part is the uses of the
Catholic Church and especially because
data in training
using study literary texts and
especially Mobile's in this book it's in
the way you mentioned the first
generation of ideas is searching
communities teachers in the 18th century
but then use different strategies that
search in eternity text some body not to
try to identify individual in text
tradition
and I too thought it was terrific and
then I did some research and realized
that a lot of the things that he says
about that trial are actually true of a
whole lot of trials which and and I was
kind of stunned because what I
specifically thought was how is it that
this
historian is ignoring history is
ignoring the history of literate
censorship trials in a way that I the
literature scholar doubt I mean
attempting to to like beginning to
dabble and in fact he ignores history so
I not sure what my point is so when a
literary think after the reason why
historians rejected one of their
although I think as a critic of others
like a brownie
my role
actually
it's merely a paper one they are to come
to completion you the relationship
between the return history and the one
hand there is horizontal way of seeing
either discourses and let's say 9:00 to
5:00
very much every
of lost knowledge so your history
discipline protectable straight to
questions
so issues and then something some sort
of sales figure which would be taken out
the trash by literature so this is one
way to see anything
me too history sighs the division there
is something which comes from the title
and the title not a federal issue cannot
be recited into English because it's sad
well which means that what and not curry
sauce some work in that sense means that
you know someone's criticizes knowledge
but it's the same institution is
internal rules of production of
knowledge is links and also do
it's perishable okay whereas consumption
more very bigger and surprise the idea
of the South Warren you know what I mean
Peter is not perishable as
and to me the the you know you mentioned
the Channel Islands analysis of Relaxo
there would be some sort of historical
knowledge
hidden thoughts of history there is
something which which mean something
very interesting very puzzling about our
relationship policy I know that
the other pastrami definition of sub
well we haven't of course it's it's not
accepted
second part is that we not argue as you
then sub law
of literature power intuition because I
think that they are star walk from the
ocean there are some well forces in with
the text
but tragedy if that is knowledge
that procreate by historians and that's
why I mentioned the fact that tradition
was very important book for 20 people
and
in tradition invention don't you know
that no can write and then this is the
fact that this knowledge is available
for in
he's an interesting government except
you see historians
we have
experience the moment now that
experience of reading literature
we story
I'm hot he's very
we can show
a story
now
okay more more briefly to your first
question so with the collapse of social
history it was really cultural history
not intellectual history that took its
place and this was associated with a few
different groups that perhaps above all
the Berkeley historians were very close
to the literary critics founding
resources and really their their object
of study was encapsulated in the title
of their journal representations which
important brought together people like
his mom loved her and so forth with with
some of the founders like Stephen
Greenblatt and Cathy Gallagher other
news sources in that Journal
interestingly ideas or philosophy per se
when we're not at least the immediate
object of interest down the line at
issue whatever they're at 100 you know
it's not necessarily
but the goal especially in greenbacks
blacks we called the inversion was in a
sense very promising to
Connect literary representations with
social practices especially concerns in
power and in some occurs early really
heartbreaking essays and that's that's a
place intellectual historians with their
attention to chiefly philosophical texts
and occasionally others were never
really willing to go and I think that's
that's troubling
or it should be willing to erode the
divide between representations and
frankly than practices and ask questions
about power but their their attitude all
along really toward practices have been
a defensive one
maintaining the autonomy of thought in
its greatness against the pollution
other things including nature it's a
project so even though I mean there are
personal connections amongst the
intellectual historians and the cultural
historian said in fact Marni JM I
mentioned is buried behind
it was
the recent period is seeing a collapse
of the prestige of cultural history in a
way with with a certain loss of what was
what was interesting and promising about
some projects which
learn from a person who is servicing
diversity the history of 19 and
she was probably a major influence so
for the
we can say that and that it was mister
disappearances
that you
you
versions of addition
okay
there is trouble
they mention
maybe she is interested
The Secret Service but it needs
cognitive damage
something between literature and
Division
my story my story fine
me Jerry
not really sure
the damages that are missing from
where this missing
I prefer big rats to give on puss in a
couple of weeks on what is missing
essentially the 19th century
he was about future documents he was
experience
very intriguing choice story
- our vision
speech
as an archive of something that is
missing
each other here not like Egyptian
Courtland as an entry into the best to
hidden parts of the past what happens
and itself an injury like that in fact a
huge continent of studies of literature
as practice practice activity a way to
to understand that the path that renews
that produced the children itself
between the children as an archive
paper and what one lane you have this
we
it was how historical understandings I
engaged in and produced by different
if you if you take some practice and
meaning you produce historical baggage
service I mean could be here in the
debate
and I think I've sorted somehow if we
take cells with the title
Coney sauce is can bring to your
objective knowledge the world subject of
and savoir
well it can be something more battery
knowledge something that is knowledge
yeah that's true but I think you know
I'm not saying that we should think of
sub well I mean the division between sub
I did not come yet I mean it comes from
the historians themselves
is that we are now entering the
scientific age and so we are doing
things
what do which are tuned to be also he
doesn't which are perishable whereas
initially will remain as a great writer
but the knowledge in which there is
knowledge and there's another